just 12 hours ago open aai released a
system called Deep research based on 03
their most powerful language model they
call it an agent and I've spent all
morning reading every note and Benchmark
that they released and testing it myself
on 20 use cases but because the name
somewhat reminded me of something I also
of course compared my results with deep
seek R1 with search and Google's deep
research yes by the way openai used the
the exact same name as Google for their
product I did hear that they were
considering calling it 03 proar mini but
instead went with one of their
competitors product names now these are
of course just my initial tests and
remember to get this thing you need to
spend $200 a month and use a VPN if
you're in Europe so bear all of that in
mind overall I am impressed but with a
pretty big caveat and I'll leave it to
you guys to judge whether it can do a
single digit percentage of all
economically valuable tasks in the world
just quickly though yes it is powered by
the new 03 model and in case you're not
familiar with all the names that's their
most powerful one not the 03 mini that
was announced just a few days ago I did
do a video on that one which is
different to 01 Pro mode which I also
did a video on and by the way both of
those are different from GPT 40 and GPT
4 anyway basically it's their best model
and they're using it to do this deep
research that's kind of all that really
matters just quickly before my test you
may have heard about a benchmark called
Humanity's last exam which I think is
pretty inappropriately titled what it
essentially tests is really Arcane
obscure knowledge and whether the model
can piece together those bits of
knowledge to get a question right so
actually it didn't surprise me that much
that on this quote Humanity's last exam
the performance when given access to the
web of this deep research agent shot up
my main takeaway from this performance
on this Benchmark is that if you want
obscure knowledge then open ai's deep
research agent is the place to go oh and
by the way the lead author of that exam
says he doesn't expect it to survive the
optimization pressures of 2025 more
interestingly for me actually was this
guia Benchmark about whether an AI can
truly be a useful assistant why would it
be more interesting well three reasons
first the tasks are more relatable
research this specific conference and
answer this specific nuanced question
that's just level one by the way and
then level three questions are things
like this one we search a very obscure
set of standards and research what
percent of those standards have been
superseded by 2023 reason number two is
that the Benchmark was co-authored by
noted llm skeptic Yan Lun here was the
state-of-the-art in April 2024 quote we
show that human respondents obtain 92%
versus 15% for GPT 4 equipped with
plugins I checked by the way and one of
those plugins was indeed GPT 4 with sech
they go on this notable performance
disparity 92% for humans versus 15% for
GPT 4 with search contrast with the
recent trend of lm's outperforming
humans on tasks requiring professional
skills leaving us with the third reason
which is that yes open ai's deep
research agent got around 72 73% on this
Benchmark that's by the way if you pick
the answer that it out puts most times
out of 64 but if you're harsher and just
pick its first answer it still gets 67%
therefore two things are true
simultaneously the performance leap in
just the last say 9 months is incredible
from 15% to 67 or 72% but it does still
remain true that human performance if
you put the effort in is still
significantly higher at 92% now just
before we get to the deeps R1 comparison
and Gemini's deep research I can't lie
the first thing that I wanted to do when
I got my hands on 03 essentially which
is hidden inside deep research is test
it on my own Benchmark simple bench it
tests spatial reasoning or you could
just say common sense or basic reasoning
unfortunately the test didn't really
work out because the model relentlessly
asks me questions instead of actually
answering the question now you could say
that that's actually a brilliant thing
because any AGI should ask you
clarifying questions I will say though
that on average it doesn't just ask you
one question it tends to ask you like
four or five even when you beg it just
to answer the question so super annoying
or a sign of AGI I'm going to let you
decide on that one but on the actual
Common Sense the actual spatial
reasoning it kind of flops I mean maybe
that's harsh I only tested it on maybe
eight of the questions but I saw no real
sign of improvement I'm not going to
spend more time in this video on
questions like this but essentially it
doesn't fully grock the real world it
doesn't get that Cassandra in this case
would still be able to move quite easily
for another question it has an instinct
that something might be up here but when
I say proceed with a reasonable
assumption on each of those points it
still flops I must admit it was kind of
interesting watching it site all sorts
of obscure websites to find out whether
a woman could move forwards and
backwards if she had her hands on her
thighs eventually I just gave up on
asking it simple bench questions because
it would keep asking me questions until
I essentially was solving the puzzle for
it multiple times by the way when I
refused to answer questions that it was
giving to me it just went silent and
kind of just stopped Pro tip by the way
if you want to get out of this Log Jam
just go to the refresh button and then
pick any other model and it will work
though still presumably using 03 which I
guess is the only one that they're using
for deep research this is what it looks
like by the way you just select deep
research at the bottom it's not actually
a model that you choose in the top left
and I'm actually going to stick on this
page because this was a brilliant
example of it doing really well I have a
fairly small newsletter read by less
than 10,000 people called signal to
noise and so I tested deep seek R1 and
deep research from Google same question
to each of them read all of the Beehive
newsletter posts from the signal to
noise newsletter written by AI explained
atal find every Post in which the dice
rating does it change everything is a
five or above print the soat sections of
each of those posts here here's my
latest post for example and if you
scroll down you can see the dice rating
here which is a three as it likes to do
it asks me some clarifying questions but
then it got to it and it found them the
two posts which had a dice rating of
five and above it also sussed out and
analyzed exactly what those dice ratings
meant and indeed printed these so what
sections I was like yeah that would
actually save me some real time if I had
to search through it myself the web
version of Deep seek was completely busy
for the entire few hours in which I
tested it but I still tested R1 how did
I do that well I used R1 in perplexity
Pro and asked the same question and
apparently there are no entries with a
dice rating of five or above obviously
perplexity is amazing and R1 with search
is incredible and they're both free up
to a point but yes if I have a
particularly difficult query I'm
probably going to use deep research it
cost me a bunch of money to subscribe to
it currently but yes I'm going to use it
speaking of usage by the way apparently
I get 100 queries per month on the pro
tier and the plus tier will have 10 per
month the free tier apparently will get
a very small number soon enough yes he
wrote plus tier but he meant free teer
how about Gemini advance and their quote
deep research and they must be furious
by the way that open AI just dumped on
their name but anyway how do they do
unfortunately in my experience it's one
of the worst options here for example it
says that it can't find any dice ratings
at all for any newsletters in signal to
noise from then on I stopped testing
deep research from Gemini and just
focused on deep research versus deep
seek the tldr is that deep research was
better than deep seek R1 pretty much
every time although it hallucinated very
frequently also deep seek didn't
aggravate me by relentlessly asking me
questions but again I'll leave that up
to you whether that's a good thing or a
bad thing I did check on your behalf if
we could force the model not to ask ask
clarifying questions and as you can see
that just does not work for this
particular query I wanted to see how
many benchmarks are there in which the
human Baseline is still double the best
current llm and they have to be up toate
the benchmarks like O3 mini has to be
tested I know my Benchmark is not
officially recognized I just wanted to
see if there were others that were text
based but still had that massive Delta
between human and AI performance as we
just saw the guia Benchmark does not
have that anymore when it asked me a
clarifying question I said Focus only on
llms for now and as I said please just
find all benchmarks that meet that
criteria no other Criterion for this
task they don't even have to be widely
recognized benchmarks please please no
more questions at that point it said
I'll let you know as soon as I find the
relevant benchmarks that fit these
conditions but then it just stopped as I
said this happens occasionally so I
prodded it go on then and then it went
and did it I was impressed again that it
did identify simple bench which is
pretty obscure as a benchmark didn't
know my name was Philip Wang though my
mother will be surprised but it did say
code ELO was another example of such a
benchmark and I was like wow there's
another one great human coders vastly
outperform current models in fact the
best models rating Falls in roughly the
bottom 20% of human code forces
participants I was like that's
interesting as with all of the outputs
though including the newsletter one I
wanted to actually check if the answers
were true and no they weren't not in the
case of code ELO where as you can see 03
mini has not been benchmarked but even
01 mini gets in the 90th percentile by
definition that means that the best
model is not in the bottom 20% of
performers now some of you may point out
that code ELO is based on code forces
and o03 mini has been tested on code
forces but nevertheless this statement
highlighted is still not true this then
for me captures the essence of the
problem that deep research is great for
finding a needle in a hay stack if
you're able to tell needles apart from
screws cuz yes it will present you both
screws and needles but remember it did
in many cases save you from scrambling
on your knees through the Hy stack so
there's that what about that exact same
question on the benchmarks but this time
to the official deep seek R1 with search
the server was working briefly for this
question so I got an answer problem is
the answer was pretty terrible I know
it's free I know it's mostly open source
and I know it's humbled the Western
Giants but that doesn't mean that deep
seek one is perfect yes Halo bench is a
real Benchmark and I did look it up it
was hard to find but I did find it
problem one though that after half an
hour of trying I could find no source
for this human evaluator's got 85%
accuracy by the way the Benchmark is
about detecting hallucinations what
about the best performing llm being GPT
4 Turbo which gets 40% if true that
would indeed meet my criteria of the
human Baseline being more than double
the best llm performance completely
untrue though as you can see from this
column where GPT 4 Turbo not only
doesn't get 40% but it's not the best
performing model actually the entire
focus of the paper is on this links
model which is the best performing model
okay now going back to deep research and
I got a cool result that I'm curious if
others will be able to reproduce in
their own domain I asked the model 50
questions about a fairly obscure Creole
language mishan Creole didn't give it
any files just clicked deep research and
waited I think it asked me some
clarifying questions yes of course it
did and I know what you're thinking
that's kind of random philli why are you
telling us about this what did it get
well it got around 88% you're thinking
okay that's a bit random but I guess
cool here's the interesting bit though I
then tested GPT 40 which is the model
most commonly used in the free tier of
chat GPT but I actually gave it the
dictionary from which these questions
came yes it's around 100 pages but
surely a model with direct access to the
source material would score more highly
alas not it actually got 82% of course
smaller models can get overwhelmed with
the amount of context they have to
digest and deep research can just spend
enormous amounts of compute on each
question and in this case at least score
more highly now I know this is totally
random but I so believed something like
this was coming I actually built a
prototype a couple of weeks ago and the
way it works is I submitted say an
article or any bit of text or a tweet
and I would get 01 to produce say
research directions that would add
context and Nuance to the article
helpful for say a journalist or a
student then each of those directions
would be sent to sonar Pro which is the
latest API from perplexity which of
course can browse the web if interesting
results were returned 2011 then it would
incorporate those if not it would cross
them out and then after going through
all Five results essentially from sonar
Pro 01 would synthesize all the most
interesting bits the most juicy bits of
of nuance and produce Like An Essay with
citations and yes it helped my workflow
all of one week until being completely
superseded Now by this deep research so
pull one out for my prototype search ay
which is now completely redundant here
it is this is the report that it
generated and you can see the citations
below let me move that down and it was
really fun and I was proud of that one
now the Slick presentation that open AI
gave did include hidden gems like is
deeper Seeker a good name in the chat
history but it didn't go into much
detail beyond the release notes about
for example what sites deep research
could or could not browse for example in
my testing it couldn't browse YouTube
although strangely it could get this
question right by relying on sources
that quoted YouTube for those who follow
the channel in my last video I asked you
guys to help me find a video in which I
predicted the open ai's valuation would
double this year which has done and it
did find the right video but not by
searching YouTube that was kind of wild
ask it for the time stamp though and
because it can't look at YouTube it
can't actually get that right what about
shopping advice though and this time I
was really specific it got to be a
highly rated toothbrush available in the
UK has to have a battery life of over 2
months and I even gave it the site to
research what the previous price history
had been essentially I wanted to know if
the purchase I had just made was a good
deal and Truth is I'd already done the
research but I just wanted to see if it
could do the same thing I had to as
usual weighed through a barrage of being
questioned SL interrogated by the model
about the details some of which I'd
already told it but nevertheless it
finally did the research and it did
indeed find the toothbrush that I had
bought so that was great unfortunately
even though I'd given it the specific
website to research in about previous
price history it didn't actually do that
none of these links correspond to camel
camel camel and that is despite by the
way saying that it had used camel camel
camel it said using camel camel camel
yes that is the name of the website but
none of the links correspond to that
website you might think well maybe it
got the answer right from the website
without quoting the website but no if
you actually go to the website you can
see that the cheapest price that this
toothbrush had been was
63 not the price quoted I think 66 by D
research in don't trust it even when it
says it has visited a site how about
deep seek R1 with search well it
completely hallucinated the battery life
claimed 70 days it's actually 30 or 35
for this toothbrush and yes we can see
the thinking but that means that we can
see it completely making something up on
the spot he said now check this site for
Amazon UK great suppose the historical
low is 40 which is not by the way it
didn't bother actually checking the site
so it gives me this hypothetical result
but by the way in the summary it states
it as a fact it's currently selling for
this notice that it actually knows that
this is a hypothetical but phrases it
like a fact in the summary now you might
say I'm being overly harsh or too
generous but honestly I'm just kind of
processing how fast things are advancing
every chart and Benchmark it seems is
going up and to the right correct me if
I'm wrong but it seems like these kind
of small hallucinations are the last
Thin Line of defense for so much of
White Collar work on one prompt I got
deep research to analyze 39 separate
references in the Deep seek R1 paper and
though it hallucinated a little bit the
results were extraordinary in their
depth in short if these models weren't
making these kind of repeated
hallucinations wouldn't this news be
effectively a redundancy notice for tens
of millions of people and I'm not going
to lie one day that redundancy notice
may come to me cuz I was casually
browsing YouTube the other to day and I
saw this YouTube channel that was
clearly AI generated the voice was
obviously AI generated I know many
people accuse me of being an AI but I'm
not but this voice trust me it was and
yet none of the comments were
referencing it and the analysis was
pretty decent and the video editing was
pretty smooth I'm sure there's a human
in the loop somewhere but come next year
or the year after or possibly the end of
this year there will be videos analyzing
the news in AI instantly the moment it
happens with in-depth massive analysis
far quicker than I can ever do obviously
I hope you guys stick around but man
things are progressing fast and
sometimes I'm just like this is a lot to
process for now though at least yes it
does struggle with distinguishing
authoritative information from rumors
although it does a better job than deep
seek R1 with search and unfortunately
much better than deep research from
Gemini not quite as good I think as me
for now but the clock is ticking thank
you so much for watching hope you stick
around even in that eventuality and have
a wonderful day